[Musique]
ce jeune acceptez vous de prendre déjà
pris pour époux c'est quoi la différence
entre mme épiscopalien et un luthérien
les épiscopaliens ne mange pas de
poisson toi tu parles dp ce qu'eta rien
c'est pas un groupe religieux ça ce sont
des fanatiques de toute façon vous
pouvez embrasser la mariée
oui si on est un groupe d'amis qui
jouent la même partie d'agde depuis 30
ans chaque année pendant tout le mois de
mai on joue à la taxe on peut attaquer
n'importe où n'importe quand
félicitations mon vieux tu y as toi
courage à notre ami joe louis c'est le
meilleur de tous les temps
il souhaite prendre sa retraite jamais
tagué sur levante qui a la taille qui
est racheté cette année au taquet
[Musique]
synchronisez vos montres j'sais pas
comment faire ça tu porte jamais de
montres le temps est relative
c'est juste un prétexte pour rester en
contact je crois que ton père aurait
vraiment voulu que je te donne la tag il
semble bien que ce jeu vous a permis
gardé des liens solides super temps te
voir aller ça fait tellement longtemps
conseiller sans toutefois la compétition
atteint des niveaux extrêmes
l'idée c'est pas de s'éviter le plus
possible au contraire c'est plutôt de
rester près les uns des autres nous est
sobre depuis combien de temps
non je suis pas seul j'ai fumé un joint
chila portail est mon ami il croit qu'il
m'a pris par surprise
cette fois je les ferai ont pris par
surprise tu déjà fait un noise est quel
genre de mauviettes bosset maire de là
[Musique]